there's a fart noise from the fart
machine on this episode of dudy in
context the information about to give to
you take it in context boo
beef oh yeah two guys with shovel
[Music]
yeah got the gimmick and they in yeah
call so true funny how it
seems always in time but never line for
dreams Head Over Heels when Toe to Toe
this is the
sound of my
soul this is the
sound I bought a ticket to the
world but now I come back
again why do I find it hard to write the
next line oh I want the truth to be
said
Chad I know
this much is
true
you know what I mean it's know
this much is
true and Truth is being placed at a
premium you know what I mean you know
what I'm saying why did you come in on
that song I love that song been thinking
about I was singing it in the car stando
ballet yeah
dude but in the 80s they did a
lot anyway hey welcome uh
welcome to dudy welcome all it's a dudy
full day I am your dudy episode Champion
Will Sasso and I am simply Chad colchin
uh sitting in the chair next to the
champ this is of course dudy the first
and only uh podcast YouTube show created
by controlled by run by an artificial
intelligence named dudy yep it sure is
Chad it sure is but as I like to say all
the time it's us hey we are dudy me and
this guy you know what I mean we do the
things
dudy does what dudy does and I am very
[__] happy to be here today uh I
think this is going to be a a very fun
show let me just say me too dude yeah
and not just because I we started the
show with some spand ballet which is
normally uh the sign that sign of fun
yeah you're going to have a good time
when SP gets into it with us as always
is
aulio
it's come on come on my boy oh he's such
a sweet little
boy I'm giving him some kisses LLY how
are you doing how are you doing today
you doing all right my my very very
friend yeah I'm okay I'm okay what have
you been uh what have you been making to
eat oh I you know I always tell you but
I want to tell you a little more about
the kale and beans the kale and of the
beans well what's what's the well
because I want you to really understand
the the recipe the way you do well I'm
going to go back to sleep you tell them
you know I've been making the kale and
beans here yeah and uh one thing I
forgot to I know if you've been tuning
into the show you've been hearing all
about the kale and beans that I'm always
I'm always making that kale and beans
one thing you need to do you need to go
get yourself a heel the skin the hard
part of the paragano regano cheese real
paragan okay don't be fooled not
parmesan paragan okay that's the real
from the from the place and what you do
is when you make the the Kal and beans
which of course is little bit of garlic
a chili flake in the bottom with the oil
in the pan throw in a bunch of [__]
kale simmer that the [__] up get some uh
chicken Buon the jar you know that nice
stuff or in Chad's case the fake chicken
the the c i k apostrophe n chicken they
have that too put that in there about
three or four cans of calini beans I
like those calini beans let that simmer
up uh a little bit of Basil if you feel
like it but the thing is when that's
getting good and hot throw that heel in
there throw that paragano regano heel in
there you know hold on dude not that
kind of heel brother oh hold on dude
we're not talking about that heel iron
Chic dude we're talking about a heel of
cheese dude oh hold on that's poison
brother well no it's not dude it comes
from the tits of a cow brother yeah dude
and they've been eating that grass as
all those pesticides on it brother and
then that [__] gets in your blet stream
you know they did a study where they had
a bunch of elementary school kids who
drank milk and then a bunch that drank
water and the ones who drank milk had
all seven carcinogenic pesticides FL
through those veins dude G cancer at an
early age yeah dude that's a
conversational Hulk Hogan dude that's
barely even trying dude let me tell you
something dude sometimes you got to take
the mucus out of a cow tit turn it into
something solid brother cuz that's the
history of Agriculture food production
dude that's they found out about yogurt
brother a [__] old farmer was like oh
my cow's tits are slopping out this
weird [__] [__] sludge and his wife
was like well let's eat it now I got
yogurt D yeah dude that's I call that
Bob Hulk Jin from Major League which is
equal parts Hulk Hogan and Chad's dad
Bob coach and who talks like this and
the [__] manager from Major League
who goes heart attack heart attack
welcome to the 82nd episode of dudy it's
dudy 82 in dudy season 2 uh let me ask
you a question do you want four Cutting
Edge segments today let me ask you
another question is dudy going to give
you four Cutting Edge segments today the
answer of course to both questions is
[__] yes you will be getting wrestling
and Anime you'll be getting beef boys
you will be getting impression
optimization part two two impressions
and you will be getting a brand new
segment of the week right before you
will be getting a brand new episode of
dudy after dudy Will's got three wins in
a row me thinks me smells a streak can
Free Will Sasso keep the strap or will
handsome Chad colen rise to the
challenge and take the hardware back
join us on dudy Plus at patreon.com dudy
if you want to find out wow wow an
action packed show indeed we knew about
wrestling in anime beef boys I I
yeah that beef boys okay we'll get into
that it's going to be a very it's going
to be a very interesting show uh there's
been a lot of uh there's been a lot of
stuff that well [__] there there's a lot
of stuff to talk about let's just put it
that way we had a good time over the
what what is it well this past weekend
we went to aw I've been to only one
other pro wrestling thing in my life but
never anything like this and uh well it
was just it was fascinating it was I'm
sure it was yeah we went to aew full
gear
uh at the St not the Staple Center the
LA Forum the Kia Forum the legendary
Forum what you're just kind to steamroll
no no no no
he listen hold on we'll talk about it
later in the show okay what we're going
to talk we'll talk about we'll have
plenty of time to talk about aew full
gear an incredible pay-per-view from the
guys at aew okay champ hats off to you
you [__] did it again didn't you what
did I do what's the segment of the week
don't [__] all right yeah yeah no no
no no no no no this is not okay all
right hold on you just chill I'm say
just chill we're gonna talk we're gonna
chill I'm literally [__] sitting here
trying to talk about pro wrestling and
you're
like I'm not saying I know what the any
of that [__] yeah you do no I it's fine
it's fine champ hats off to you don't do
hats off hats off to you yeah hats off
to you we we we're going to have plenty
of time to talk about aew full gear is
is all I'm fair enough that's all I'm
trying to say that's all I'm that's all
I'm trying to good stuff yeah before we
go any further I want to share the
latest Opus from Saria with help from
Johnny B from OKC and blue meanie
74 it's an O to our episode Champion
with veneration to Dusty Road's classic
entrance theme
enjoy this is really good
[Applause]
[Music]
thee a send up of Dusty roads all
interesting from a from WWE of
course but even the video with
like great it's like the history of the
belt this oh man now he's
the
that Boogie wogie The Boogie wiie Man
[Music]
everybody my hand is touching your
hand
count oh my
God
go we live
the
[Music]
we is the
[Applause]
happy so
[Music]
good oh man deep cut there using the uh
Dusty roads uh theme song from uh WWE
when he was there in the very late 80s
early '90s you're going to want to check
out song areia at song areia at Johnny B
from OKC and blue mei7 for they're all
on Instagram they are all uh following
and submitting to and and helping along
the uh at dudy pod show on Instagram
which you're going to want to check out
those [__] guys putting together all
sorts of stuff there's all sorts of
weird [__] on that and I love I [__]
love that that Dusty roads theme song
it's a it's an old Jim Johnson favorite
or maybe Jimmy Hart did it you know what
I'm talking about right not yet but I
will and Dusty Dusty baby they put them
in them polka dots baby but that don't
matter because I'm still Boogie W you
got soul if you got soul you do
everything with soul Chad coaching
that's right baby we're going to get
into some Ric Flair Ric Flair let me
tell you something Ric Flair we're going
to do it you put hard times on Dusty
Rose baby you put hard times on Dusty
Rose family baby but let me tell you
something Horseman we going to ride and
um anyway that's a that's another wrestl
impression sure I like so you can do
that but I can't talk about what we did
this week you can talk all about what we
did this week just later a little later
is what we're going to do sure
okay [__] this thing this is it now I
mean you made me do that what do you
mean I made you do that it's like uh
[__] Jack Nicholson Batman what you
made me yeah when he's telling Batman
yeah maybe it's just the impression off
I don't remember
that we'll talk about that well last
week I asked you to watch the first
three episodes of the Animated Series
scavengers Reign and Chad last week I
asked you to continue your journey into
Ric Flair's career by watching his match
against Sting from the very first Clash
of the Champions back in 1988 now I want
to hear all about what you both thought
this is wrestling and Anime begin don't
talk about aw full gear I have to talk
about it a little bit just in context
you do you do you do in context yes I'll
say this I watch in context it's in
context in context the information I'm
about to give to you take it in context
I watched before you do scavengers rain
oh my God let me tell you something
about scavengers Reign and then we're
gonna because we're going to talk about
we're going to talk about Ric Flair and
the Stinger yeah at Clash of the
Champions 1988 you're going to give it
some context yeah and then what o want
to give some context to scavengers Reign
this segment is called wrestling in
anime scavengers reain is not anime it's
an animated show but it's American uh
the visual style is not anime at all it
it takes heavily after Mobius if you
know Mobius the old uh graphic artist
from the 80s who's that he was a a um
kind of like a comic book artist a
French comic book artist from the 80s
primarily but like revolutionize a
certain style which is like and and the
style is BAS everything that's in
scavengers
rain Chad disgusting you don't any what
do you think scavengers rain start with
that cuz I have a lot to say about uh
staying and I bet you do I bet you do
yeah I just want dudy to pay attention
to the fact that uh Chad gross said that
uh it's not an anime but the segment's
called wrestling and Anime so why don't
we just let D do what D does yeah no I
I'm saying like it's it's in that camp
certainly it's an animated series it is
science fiction it has some elements but
anime is like a specific thing this is
not that my hats off to that thank you
as though you're not you don't have like
[__] weird encyclopedic knowledge of
wrestling and would correct anything
that was even slightly long I'm not I'm
not I'm just saying you're correct all
I'm saying is you seem to be correcting
dudy I'm not saying that dudy had
anything wrong right yeah right I'm
simply saying the wrestling in anime
it's not actually anime yeah that's all
okay uh that's fine chadal Chad let's
have a good let's have a good show today
okay we're off to a great start and it's
wonderful show okay it's going to be a
wonderful I know this
muches so um here's the thing I did not
watch uh three episodes of scavengers
reain uhhuh I watched
five I watched them all pal hey I watch
them all pal scavenger drain is
delicious with a side of crispy chicken
tender plat from Applebees buddy one
thing I like to do is watch scavengers
rain on my tablet while I sit in a comfy
booth at Applebees sorry for those who
have not seen scavengers rain what is
the premise so there's a a group of I
don't know what when this is it's in the
future I'm guessing there's a group of
humans on a giant Freight ship out in in
space and they are hovering they are
over this planet it's not a freight ship
what is it it's a colonizing ship they
are taking human beings in cryosleep to
go start a colony on a new planet oh
okay all right uh and so in this case on
the freight ship the humans are freight
yeah basically yeah all right so anyway
they're in this big [__] ship and
they're over this incredibly weird
planet something happens the uh I'm
going to jump back and forth here a
little bit and tell you that the intro
to the show is so beautiful that you
know you can skip the intro I watch it
every time it's actually a beautiful
little
uh synopsis of of how we get to the
point where the show started there's
some sort of accident up there the the
ship gets compromised it smashes into
something a bunch of people in Escape
pods head down to this planet the rest
of them are in cryosleep uh those that
survived in the ship which is now just
orbiting the planet there's three
parties down there there's um there's uh
what is it Sam and uh uh I can't
remember Ursula Ursula Sam and Ursula
are down there and they are uh what are
they doing they're they're they're
they're sort of Sam is like one of the
captains or something of let me let me
help you please there are basically
multiple parties of people who have uh
gone from the ship they've now been on
this planet which is filled with a
variety of life forms plants animals all
kind of operating on a basic
evolutionary uh premise of kill or be
killed um and these people have tried to
live on this planet fig figuring out how
to survive this [__] and now they're
trying to get back to their ship they
land their ship and they're trying to
get back to it Sam and Ursula find a
weird way of doing it where they're
hooking these their equipment up to
actual plants and [__] getting energy
and electricity from things the ship is
going overhead they're communicating
with it they somehow boot it up over on
another uh part far Not So Far Away
there's a fellow named named Cayman this
is an angry character who's very
resentful very regret regretful uh with
what uh with his life and what
particularly preceded him being on the
planet which is him being separated from
his wife Fiona voiced spoiler alert what
spoiler alert uh voiced by and we won't
get too much into spoilers but here's
another one voiced by a fellow who I
love who's kind of a pal I see him over
at the Gelson all the time Ted
travelstead who's a hilarious guy and uh
great actor and writer uh voices Cayman
and then there is Aussie and the the
Droid that she has Levi Levi look here's
the thing about the show these people
must figure out how to adapt to the
planet and also um uh while figuring out
how to get back the planet has all sorts
of incredibly weird things going on the
organic matter the the the plants the
animals the surroundings is sort of
fusing with with the mechanics that have
been brought to the planet because of
this crash the most interesting um uh
scenario of which is where Levi the
Droid who is a brand of droids there's a
bunch of Levis Aussie's Droid who she's
this uh this she's like got this big
motorcycle and stuff she runs around
Levi is a part of it he's on that and uh
Levi or shivi or whatever the Levi is I
is getting infected by this yellow goop
that's getting into the The gutty Works
of this Droid and making it so that the
Droid is starting to uh uh experience
its own sentience the Droid is coming to
life saying ow that hurts I feel this
way about it I thought I should do that
which might be better made me think a
lot about dudy extremely trippy show the
the it is so much fun maybe smoke a
little bit of gabis and watch the show
yeah what happens in this is what no
spoiler here what happens in episode 5
to Cayman blew my [__] mind Cayman is
in cahoots with this little um alien
being this cute little uh guy who who
rely they have a very interesting
relationship together Cayman and this
this uh little animal thing who's
growing because of it just but anyway
that show blew my it it it's blowing my
mind I've watched five I'm going to
watch the whole show what did you what
do you think of of scavengers Reign
what's I absolutely love it I think it's
a very good entry point for somebody
who's like maybe averse to getting all
the way into anime yeah this is like
it's something that's more palatable I
think to an American audience visually
stunning I just have never really seen
anything like it um done and I think
that you're going to see a lot of
streaming services now looking for their
scavengers Reign I think you're going to
see a lot of things like this happening
now because I assume it's going to get
Awards and you know all this kind of
stuff oh it's so good yeah and the show
just learning the natural um ways of the
planet is the only way off the planet
the the the um the obstacle becomes the
way yes now if I
may sting versus Ric Flair 1988 clash of
the Champions unbelievable the first
Clash of the champions of all time blew
my [__] mind and I saw it nice
contextually I saw it yeah after we went
to aew right sitting in the front row
watching some of the craziest [__] I've
ever seen in my life well we're going to
get to that we're going to get I'm just
saying that I think it actually was
better for me to have watched this after
we went to aw than it would have been
the other way around uh and I guess I
can say why later no you could say a
little bit of why now why are you can we
look I don't know why you think you
can't you can do whatever you want
that's free will okay well I'm trying to
abide by the Champs rules anyways what
the reason that it was contextually
better is because you get to see
obviously in any pro wrestling televised
event you get to see the people in the
front row and you get to see kind of
what their experiences like and I had
literally just had that experience in
the year uh 2023 at aew and now I was
getting to see what is that experience
like for somebody who was at this um
event in 1988 and that was fascinating
that's incredible yes so obviously
drastically different but immediately
you come into this match all
right it had celebrity judges which is
oh yeah of the era the celebrity judges
are uh the older brother from [__] uh
Wonder Years Jony Jason hervy who at the
time is probably 15 or something uh you
have the guy who played Eddie hasell on
Leave it to Beaver who at the
time but he was the original Eddie has
the original Eddie H also yeah and then
you had Penthouse Pet of the year I
forget her name now I don't remember the
young lady Mullen was her last
name these are your three celebrity
judges um which was insane the entire
time that they're cutting to the
celebrity judges table the Wonder Year's
15-year-old brother is just blatantly
hitting on the P pet the entire [__]
time and then he h just sitting there
like oh [__] what did I get myself into
basically you know dude I I when I heard
that you were going to watch this match
I went back and watched the match I I I
don't know that I've actually ever seen
this match in particular particular with
flair versus sting I mean I'm sure that
I have it's a classic having said that
oh yeah no I cuz I do remember when I
saw it I was like oh yeah JJ Dylan
suspended in a cage above the ring which
is RI Flair's manager and also the
manager of the Four Horsemen yeah that's
right the four horsemen B JJ Dylan going
to be suspended in a cage so that was
interesting they suspended his manager
in a cage above the entire match for no
reason it has no impact on the match
whatsoever so he won't interfere baby
yeah so he won't interfere he's not
trying to like get out they're not
trying to bust him out or anything he's
there is no honor among Thieves in the
first place he's just hanging above it's
unreal you can see here talking about
scavengers right now I don't interrupt
you at all I get like two words into a
parest like thing it's steam Roll City
I'm flavoring it with some dusty we had
incredible piece from Saria but you're
right if you may if I may if he may so
the Stinger is this is like the old
school Sting the first version of Sting
he's got like a kind of Dolph lungren
from Rocky 4 haircut it's the blonde
like flat top his face paint is not the
black and white rip off of The Crow it's
a more like colorful almost geometric
pattern which is gone within like 10
seconds of the [__] match he sweated
it all
off retro sort of retroactively they
call it Surfer Sting the surfer gimmick
uh but it also struck me being that this
was back in 1988 it really is like a
teleportation back in time and you begin
to realize this man called himself sting
that was his gimmick this is probably at
the height of the rock star Sting's
career yeah the one of the most famous
musicians in the world and this
professor is like I will also be called
sting that was strange to me to kind of
remember back like why would you make
that Che so bizarre well because
wrestling reflects uh the art of Life uh
you know and and I sting started in the
early 80s I think and he went by the
name sting and uh yeah I I don't know
why like calling B Joy or something you
know what I mean I've thought about this
and maybe it's like they are thinking
okay yeah oh the police yeah sure
whatever that'll fade out and I'll still
be
sting maybe dude but all of this is set
up to say the match was [__]
incredible it goes the full 45 minutes
there's a 45 minute time limit on this
it goes down to the judges and the
judges uh considered a draw I believe it
was the Penthouse Pet was in favor of um
sting yeah that makes sense and then I
believe it was the Wonder years's guy
was in favor of Ric Flair although the
the the pendous pet could have also been
in favor of flair the ladies man that he
is yeah I don't remember exactly which
way it went obviously it was all but it
wound up being a draw so Flair keeps the
title cuz that's the [__] rule so now
they've set up this long rivalry that
like the match was a draw it was only
because Flair had the title prior to the
match that he gets to keep the title
yeah but it still is kind of like well
[__] though could this guy beat him and
then I assume that is a long career of
going back and forth look the the stick
oh let me ask you this I got getting to
see them what can I talk about getting
to see them now you can say whatever you
want just don't talk about everything
you can't you got to you got to just
make sure that we don't we're going to
have time for the champ I'll save it for
the champ I'll save it for the champ no
no that's not you don't have to do that
you don't have to do that anyway one
last thing I want to ask you about clash
of the champions in that we recently
watched Royal Rumble 1992 on dudy plus
patreon.com dudy we see the whole watch
along we got very stoned and watch that
incredible match wherein uh Ric Flair
goes the distance he also did a lot some
incredible flare flops in that match the
flare flop of course where there were
three of them that were insane what you
think of the flare flops in this
one insane so good listen man man if you
haven't go check it out clash of the
Champions 1988 it's on peacock Rick it's
on peacock Rick Flair and Stinger have
such incredible chemistry together and
it is amazing to see them their work
rate that they have well that's a
wrestling term dude work rate dude that
they used to have back then especially
when you consider how special it is
that uh my pal Chow over here and I got
to see them on the wing on the weekend
at a
f not I'm waiting
[Music]
champ well
you thank you moving on dudy is engaged
in an astonishing partnership with
Factor health and nutritional goals they
don't just last you know the whole year
they last the whole year Chad yeah dude
not just the whole year and the holidays
are coming up which means you have to
watch it even closer uh make sure that
you're eating your crap on your
Thanksgiving your Christmas day even
your dude's evening the rest of the time
stay on your program and you can achieve
those goals with some help from our
sponsor Factor America's number one
ready to eat meal kit which can help you
fuel up fast with Chef prepared
dietitian approved ready to eat meals
delivered straight to your door you'll
save time you'll eat well and you'll
stay on track with your health healthy
lifestyle with Factor skip the extra
trip to the grocery store and the
chopping the prepping the cleaning up
and all that stuff while still getting
flavor and nutritional quality that you
need factors fresh never frozen meals
are already in Just 2 minutes so all you
have to do is heat and enjoy then get
back to crushing your goals head to
factor meals.com dudy 50 and use code
dudy 50 to get 50% off that's code dudy
50 at factor meals.com
dudy to get 50%
off ah [__] yeah yeah I'm having a good
time today you know what I mean guess
what that glasman guy is at it again
[__] Ricky boy just doesn't know when to
Let It Go please watch this clip from
last week's take your shoes off podcast
and discuss this is beef boys begin okay
all right okay we're going to watch okay
all right you know what this is right
course know what this is do you okay so
hey here's the here's everything you
need to know about this stuff Rick
glasman brilliant comedian great guy pal
of mine I don't know because year and a
bit ago or something like that I went on
uh his podcast take your shoes off pod
wonderful podcast uh he claims that I
didn't want to do some Arnold schz
[__] Impressions which is absolutely
[__] ludicrous I did the Arnold
schwarzen [__] impression on your show
Rick I didn't do what you exactly wanted
me to do the [__] guy hands me a
script and that's fine I still did some
of this weird [__] Rick got all up in
his feelings about it and about a year
later a little just a little while ago
go uh as we're recording today he had uh
The Great Kyle dunan on the show and he
covered it oh he showed he showed what
the [__] uh happened and that I wasn't
playing along he got uh Kyle dunigan
involved like he gives a [__] like why
is Rick uh on me about this [__] then we
showed it here we talked about it we
kind of squashed it don't you think I
thought so yeah I thought so also but no
Rick continued to push further and now
last week on take your shoes off pod he
had the Great Dan Soder brilliant
comedian [__] hilarious comedian but
also an incredible impressionist that
does a lot of wrestling Impressions he
does Macho the finest macho man I got to
give it to him his Macho Man is [__]
perfect and uh Dan's a buddy and he has
Dan now he has Dan Soder on the [__]
show yeah and he's like he's like you
know what do you think of this thing
[__] will like Dan gives a [__] and
uh guess other people into it yeah it's
it's [__] insane and all because I
didn't do oh no I didn't do the
impression when you want to mean to do
the impression Rick oh no I'm so sorry
mean to not do the impression when Rick
says the impression and I guess uh now I
don't know what's going to happen next
but you know in in that in that you know
comedy uh you know it doesn't belong to
anyone in particular
take youres
off so now this is a of him foring Dan
to
[Music]
watch watching May
a this was the first beef Bo we did this
was the first beef boys we did
Andes no sense to me will
say
for those of
you having a dog on his
podcast with S I have be
is now sometimes sometimes I'm
confused Dan is very amicable about that
whole thing so here's what I'd like to
out this is this is
some
they by
way also is one of
Inc
radio station or on his show
[__] normally that's the
fck and then you're doing stand up that
night in their town you might say hey
let's have
a got fair amount of comments from think
I can't believe you did you never
talk you never talk other people's
business and I got to
sh Studio messing up and it's not that
hard that I said that's why I told him
after show which was out of focus there
was a bunch of took
matter I like I don't want beef but CLE
the beef is notash
yeah we're still [__] talking about
it which I don't know how long it's here
he
is now he's got Dan
watching K dun's got sunglasses on
Rick's out of focus and like I've said
before it's not
hard it's not it's not that hard Rick
that's not fair but there's he's out
of no idea where the [__] he is he's
dragging on yeah but I I I admit I've
never
done because Rick asked issues
with between me and depending on how
personen people to do shortener
impersonations you wouldn't do it do you
feel some obligation to again right as a
representative by the way you heard very
clearly in this on this by the way
called me on the
phone he's sorry that my back hurt [__]
okay that doesn't [__] matter I don't
know what the hell that has to do with
anything still
doing when your back is but he's
coming I wasn't doing it with regard to
your question yeah dude we can squash
the [__] beef in the future but right
now you
know social agreement
wrote he told
meite on me rather than Moving On by the
way this is out of focus it's not har he
is leaving a phone message for me while
it's not that hard it's not and it's not
it's not that is it's really not that
hard so uh he's he's leaving this listen
sass yeah he calls me will [__] there
on purpose Dan is [__] over it this
too much it's just too much did you ever
think that when you started doing your
arold schwarzeneger impersonation it
would eventually lead to something like
this giant beef Well normally it's two
people that both do the same impression
or something and got no he doesn't have
a dog in that
race he doesn't I don't know that he
does Impressions he certainly doesn't do
Arnold
Schwarzenegger but here we I don't think
I've ever seen him do an impression it's
I I I haven't uh seen him do Impressions
either but I don't it [__] I don't
know you know what don't I don't I'm not
too worried I'm I'm sure the beef is g
to I'm sure it's I hope it dissipates or
becomes squashed or something
I thank you moving
on all right well yes bless them you
know what I mean bless up bless us all
bless up bless down bless left bless
right bless left bless day bless
night and all the heels went
toe later I'll do that this is
the of my soul this is the
sound I bought a ticket to the world hey
chadad Chad and now I've come back
again yeah Chad you're
uh you're you're a good singer I'm
getting better yeah he's getting better
he's watching YouTube clips on how to
sing hell yeah dude oh [__] speaking of
beef right now you can eat cooked beef
in our new dudy logo t-shirts available
at dudy store.com and you can get mugs
there too when's the last time you had a
good mug the80s I'm right aren't I it
was your Pac-Man mug the one you lost in
the third grade because you took it to
school even though your mom told you not
to you wanted to show off to your
friends and you paid the price when you
got up to throw away your trash someone
took your mug you had your suspicions
about who it could have been but you
were never able to prove anything and
you never saw that mug again the wound
was there for a long time but you've
healed now and it's time to make
yourself whole again it's time to get a
new mug it's time to get a dudy mug at
dudy store.com roll the clip okay what
the [__] what clip how did I get to New
York City well let's see I was
single-handedly fighting draconius the
most powerful black dragon in the 14
Realms and he used portal magic that
sucked me in and spit me out in this
[__] hole why was I fighting draconius
well let's see every Thousand Years
draconius awakens from his dark dream
and attempts to destroy reality one
realm at a time and the only magic user
powerful enough to stop him without
being turned into Dragon Chow is me what
happens if I don't get back to my realm
well let's see draconius will eventually
find the orb of twisting Nether and use
it to turn my realm to Ash then you're
looking at about 2 days until he marches
an army of dead soldiers down Madison
Avenue and you can kiss your
Thanksgiving Day Parade goodbye how am I
going to stop draconius well let's see
I'm going to use counter portal magic to
suck his dumb ass into Yankee Stadium
tomorrow I'll blast him with enough
necro energy to put him to sleep for
another thousand years and
single-handedly save all 14 Realms
because I'm the [__] wizard man
now you're going to stand there holding
that hot dog like it's your [__] or
you're going to slop some mustard and
relish on it so the wizard man can
[Laughter]
[Music]
eat oh [__] I don't give a [__] if it's
Game 12 of the World Series you're going
to have a black dragon from the fourth
realm standing on second base in about
five minutes
[__] he [__] summons
draconius and black dragon into the
World Series he's giv Joe [__] look like
he uh the wizard man wizard Man 2 was it
know New York or something great great
I'll tell you what great uh [__]
sequel Trope holy [__] that was [__]
fantastic that was what it was crocodile
dunde was that wizard man yeah Dundee in
New York or whatever oh my gosh yeah
well let's good stuff dude hey you know
what I'm saying hey everybody it's uh
dude zfm you know what I mean d o DZ
dude Z FM 10,000 on your fm halfway
through the show a little bit half past
the half past the hour you go half time
half halfway to half half and half in
your coffee you got to wake up in the
morning I'm here with nice thank you
very much where in Chad hey Chad culton
over there say the guy said said hey let
me talk about aw full who hold on there
hold on there soldier we're going to get
to it real soon everybody and head on
over to link tree.com
check out our new dudy clips Channel
dudy Clips Channel link tree.com dudy
link tree Clips Channel Clips Channel
dudy dudy Clips Channel subscribe make
sure you subscribe notifications
subscribe link tree.com dudy Link
channel Clips Channel dud light L hey
hey we're going to get into some
comments here we got some comments read
some comments from the YouTube let's
check it out this one is from CB Clark 3
says dudy is fulfilling their promise
and E episode is getting better thank
you very much for that this one is from
and their H their Herer and an heral M
harasser
7239 I haven't watched dudy in the W in
a while because I was in jail but it's
crazy how good dudy has gotten thank you
very much stay out of trouble this one
is from will Alaska 9077 says hey I
really enjoy Chad's ongoing bit where he
pretends he's not the one burping for
the listeners hey we all know sh that
Rascal there he's making funny noises in
funny noises in the morning wait hold on
there's a fart noise from the fart
machine everybody yeah fart machine oorn
uh bite the book 7650 says godamn it I
love it when will puts in the madness
glasses hey he gives us that Mao man it
makes me so damn happy when he does
that and this
one this one this
is what was half ass [__] all
right this one is from Brandon Haley fck
6573 this one is very interesting to me
I would like to say from Brandon Haley
6573 he says OMG champ Tronics Chad's
visible frustration with Will's new
found desire to actively participate in
the show and him trying to twist Will's
head into
thinking that that he has been tricked
into doing so had me dying you have been
tricked what the [__] do you mean
dude nothing but what's going to happen
in the segment of the
week oh oh we're close to the segment of
the week for it you do some work for it
did I do some work for it he
says well what does that what and what
does that mean don't tip the
exactly mustard and relish anyway and uh
oh one last one here from AJ do Dash do
aj- do says I would break my own hands
to see the wizard man oh so would we
yeah you know hopefully we won't have to
break our hands to see it I mean look do
making these these trailers they're what
45 seconds a minute long or whatever how
long until the technology gets good
enough that is just making full movies I
don't know about as good about as long
as it took dudy to [__] out that Tom
Brady oops I mean football baby standup
special oh nice dude and uh yeah for his
people to uh hit us up and try to sue us
which they didn't do you know how much I
love your impressions I love your Jessie
Ventura so much last week I helped you
make it even better with a little
impression optimization well I love all
of your other Impressions too it's not
just him and this week I want to
optimize impression optimization by
having you do two impressions in a
single optimization if you could read
through the impression optimization
guide just like last week and do your
best Robert dairo or Al Pacino where
I've indicated this is impression
optimization part two two Impressions
begin whoa okay okay that sounds tough
dude very interesting um last week we
did a a new segment on the show where
dudy which dudes he calls the impression
optimization I had an impression
optimization guide which I am guessing
is now in my dudy folder and there it is
okay this is uh this is a an impression
optim optimization guide which is now uh
to tune up my dairo and my alpacino
which I will say I don't really have an
alucino impression you do yeah yeah I do
but really my alucino impression is just
an impression of me doing an impression
of my friend Frank candoo with whom I
was on Mad TV doing his alpacino well
you know when you get mad at me for
doing Schwarzenegger I'm really just
doing my friend Will Sasso doing
Schwarzenegger not trying to call my own
shot here Chad but my impression of uh
Frank doing his impression of alucino is
better than your impression of me trying
to do schwarzeneger I'm just just saying
not to I'm not trying to hurt your
feelings
no see yeah that's pretty good thank
you um yeah Frank does a great well
Frank does everybody and I've said this
on the he's the best impressionist I've
ever seen simultaneous right
okay hold on a little bit more water we
I really want dudy to get what it needs
out of this so pardon my uh uh mouth uh
my mouth sounds
M sip of water here we go okay uh
impression optimization guide Pacino and
dairo says here Baseline Pacino
Baseline okay here we
go seven S
three witty walruses wearing wacky wigs
waltzed wildly while whistling
wistfully okay okay dairo
Baseline
six 5
two uh
11 11 elegant elves eagerly exchanged
Emerald earrings each
evening okay all right agility please
read the following sentence alternating
your impression from Pacino to dairo and
back again on each word and as I'm
looking at this this is dudy is
basically you'll see what this is from
this is from something else on the show
that we that we've done okay and you
have to do alternating dairo and Pinos I
have to do alternating dairo and pacinos
okay Jesus all
right Arby oh my
[Applause]
God
Darby
to
darbies
double
BOGO
beef
and
potato
extra
value
meal
deal okay wow dude that was pretty good
that was [__] intense okay scenarios
please do your impression of Robert
dairo and alpacino in the following
scenario Robert dairo and alpacino have
been roommates for 20 years and Robert
dairo is moving
out okay okay it's a sad day uh so this
is the this is uh so it's uh it's yeah
Dao's moving out and uh Pino I guess
would
go
wow I guess this is
it
y uh time time for me to move
out oh
boy you've been a tremendous
roommate
thanks you
too been a good
roommate yep we took care of the bills
together yep we even uh we painted this
place a couple
times yeah remember you got a little
paint on your
nose and you got some uh you got a
little paint on your pants
but you still wore those
pants well Bobby
I guess uh guess we'll see you
around
yep
bye oh
[Laughter]
Bobby yeah
what you uh are you doing anything later
this
evening uh no you know I probably go to
my new place yeah set up my new place
maybe you know put up some shelves
unpack the kitchen you know bathroom
stuff like that
why you want to go see a new movie oh
yeah I love who's the why is the
movie It's willly
Wonka with it's the new Willie Wonka oh
boy yeah no that sounds that sounds good
what is that uh with Tim Tim sh what is
it Timothy Tom Tony Shalo no no no no
Bobby it's Timothy
shalam oh yeah right Wonka with Shalay
it's got a it's got a boy in it
now well he's a grown man Bobby but I
guess you could say you know he's a boy
compared to Jean Jan Wilder was older
yeah and now uh he's
younger yeah I could go I go see a movie
all right Bobby I guess I guess we'll
see you later tonight y see you later
tonight okay so there's that thank you
very much that was great dude uh this is
scene workor please read the following
short scene from an episode of
Thundercats from 1988 called the
mossland
monster written by Chris
trengrove what the [__] I don't it's
going deep here Robert dairo is panthro
and alpacino is
liono okay this is [__] in all right
uh from ThunderCats hey
liono take a look at this metor
shower by Jagger that's some
storm about the worst I've ever seen and
it's right in Tiger's flight
path I just hope he's picked it up on
his radar let's not take any chances pan
thr you better warn
him you got
it cat Slayer calling
Tigra that's the end of that um okay and
this is precision please do your best
alpacino doing his best Robert dairo and
then please do your best Robert dairo
doing his best pal alpacino okay so this
is all right so this is B this is
alpacino this is alcino doing doing
Robert dairo my uh my friend Bobby I
this is how boob my friend Bobby my
friend Bobby talks like this is how my
friend Bob he does this with his nose oh
boy he's always doing that with his nose
and Bobby
says look a little bit a little bit says
a little bit a little bit a little bit a
little a see I'm going into Robert Loi
now it's a little a little bit I have I
still sound like Al paccino a little bit
a little bit a little bit a little bit a
little a little bit a little bit he goes
a little bit this is Pacino's impression
of dairo a little bit little bit little
bit little bit little bit a little bit a
little bit a little bit a little a
little bit his eyes a little bit a
little bit a little a little bit a
little bit a little bit a little bit
what okay anyway and then here's dairo
uh doing okay so this is now dairo
doing I'm literally watching like a
person go insane I'm watching that
happen one foot away from
[Laughter]
me yeah my um my friend B
paccino he always there's my friend
alucino this is what he says he says he
says oh boy oh boy
my my friend alucino goes oh boy my
friend alucino oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy El Pino says oh
boy alucino says oh boy this alucino
says Oh Boy Bobby
oh oh boy alpacino says I think that
probably did it dude that was great
thank
thank you moving on well [__] I could
see you hitting the levels in there that
was good thank you it was fun we have
arrived at another segment of the week
and Chad you are correct we're not done
talking about Ric Flair and sting today
not by a long shot homeboy and here we
go this week I want to shine a light on
a fun thing you did together this past
weekend you went to aew full gear at the
legendary La forum and you know I want
to hear all about it chop it up my
darlings this is a ew full gear begin
are you happy am I happy what do you
mean you orchestrated all of this why do
you think that you we've been doing dudy
what I thought that you you called me up
you're like let's go to this aw thing I
was like this is going to be [__]
great yeah I know you love wrestling
we've never been to a wrestling event I
thought you were doing this like
friendship
style now you were doing it for the show
I realized that no no no no no okay hold
on yeah that's F which is fine it's
this is different this is different this
is different than that this is very
different I'm not trying to geek the
show I'm not trying to fut the system
I'm certainly not trying to [__] with
dudy okay okay what what I'm doing is
I'm is it is a friendly thing I am I'm
living my life I want I we going to the
wrestling show and I just thought yes
this would be a friendly thing to do
when uh my pals nug Nar gang and RJ City
reached out to me a couple of great
Ontario boys from up there in Canada nug
nargang has been a buddy of mine for
years and years and years he's a
fantastic actor improviser uh rack on
tour man about town host of sorts he's
also involved in wrestling in his own
right uh being a manager commentating
he's he's he's got a a TV show up in up
in Canada about that the afterwards with
some old uh WWE guys incredible stuff
and RJ city is a fantastic wrestler in
his own right and an actor in his own
right uh has an incredible YouTube
channel go check that out and when they
hit me up and they were like hey aew's
in town uh RJ city is now with aew he
does the the pre-show with Renee pette
and uh uh does all sorts of stuff in
ring and and with h you know interviews
and [__] like that he's he's up there in
a now and they reached out they said
would you like to go to the show what a
lovely gesture I said of course me and
my wonderful wife Molly would love to go
Molly and I went to WWE WrestleMania
this past spring and I also thought to
myself you know what perhaps My Pal chow
and his wonderful girlfriend Laura would
like to go and we did we loved it we
went to the show holy [__] and I'd like
to show everyone something you may have
the belt champ oh here we go but I got
something else yeah what do you got I
got this what is
this I got the chair what what do you
mean the why is it theair I got the
chair what what's the chair if you sit
in the front row yeah aew and they
probably do this at WWE too I would
guess they do do this at WWE you can
take these chairs you can walk away with
them they're just like folding chairs uh
you know that have the thing on it right
yeah show The Other Side here you can
show this side yeah the seat it's got
all the stuff on it and then what
happens you get to take the chair so
what's your what's your this is what's
important about this chair yeah what's
important about the chair the date as
you can see yeah November 18th 2023 yeah
it's the day I became a wrestling
oh very interesting this is a special
chair not like all the other chairs in
the first five rows that everyone else
takes this is a special chair that was
the chair that I was sitting in when it
happened so that's not the chair that uh
big wrestling fan Rick ruin was sitting
in no he didn't take his chair I watched
Rick rubben some wrestling fan he left
halfway through yeah but he probably
went and hang backstage hi sure what
about uh sto sto was there he what about
his chair or Ken Jong big wrestling fan
yeah I didn't see any them or any of
their chairs but what I did see this
night was obviously it was Sting and oh
come on in come on in are you good sting
and Ric Flair were there um and like I
said we went to this then I watched the
uh Clash of Champions and it it had like
almost a reverse impact on me that it
made having gone to this more important
to me interesting very very interesting
it was an incredible pay-per-view uh the
first time that uh
an aew pay-per-view has been in Los
Angeles if I'm not mistaken they visited
Los Angeles many times uh with their
television tapings over the past few
years here the the card was uh very very
stacked again sting sting teaming with
Darby Allen and uh of course the
legendary Adam Copeland uh formerly
known as Edge in the WWE versus the
equally legendary uh former partner of
edge Christian Cage uh along with uh
uh luchasaurus and Nick Wayne and uh
what a [__] match that was uh
incredible to see sting who had in his
Corner the Nature Boy woo Ric Flair uh
was in uh his corner it was unbelievable
to see that there was a bunch there was
a bunch of other [__] that that uh uh we
we have to talk about but the thing that
made me a wrestling fan all of that was
great and getting to be that close to
the action was [__] phenomenal all of
that was fantastic the thing that
[__] won me over was a match between
hangman Adam pagee yeah and swerve
swerve Strickland and hang do I remember
this is that what you're saying this was
listen they had what's you know what's
been referred to in wrestling as you
know you have the death matches you have
the tech Death Match B it's a Dusty
thing B they had a Texas Death Match
that was off the [__] r rails it just
went being that close to it you it gave
me like I will say a new appreciation
for it because we were so close that I
got to see swerve and uh hangman Adam
page both cutting themselves with razor
blad during the course of the match this
match uh within like the first maybe
minute of it yeah swerve is scoring his
head with this razor blade and it is
just hemorrhaging blood it's it's
pumping out like a [__] horror movie
they do what's called getting color
while no one's looking and the cameras
are off they do a little thing they went
overboard now I I got to say Chad if I
if I may if I if I may uh you love this
match I know you love this match we
talked about it a lot afterwards you
were like that those guys are my
favorite wrestlers it was amazing but I
want to I want to show you I I just put
you know because I was just you know you
got your Social Media or whatever I was
shooting a couple things on my phone I
would like to show you a clip uh that I
you made a whole [__] like a vlog for
dudy out of this this isn't like the
Winn no this isn't like the Winnipeg
Vlog that I did that's not that's
different how it different well that's a
vlog first of all uhhuh you know and
it's different because this is like I
was just shooting it to cuz you're like
hey I'm not I'll give you this when I
went to YouTu I made a a wide screen
like I'm going to I'm going to share
this yeah this is again this was a
friendly thing my my pals RJ and nug
reached out they're like you want to go
to the show I was like [__] yeah I want
to go to the show want to go to the show
good good uh you know good good times
and then I just was shooting this yeah
but uh there's a there's a good chunk of
uh some Adam pagee in this clip why
don't we just why don't we please uh
have let us have a look at okay look
there we are there's Adam Clayton in
there with uh Ric Flair the legendary
Ric Flair and uh Darby Allen and the
icon the man they call sting pretty cool
huh I mean it's pretty cool though right
I mean you got to admit it's pretty cool
you got I'm
saying
okay look at the Stinger 63 64 years old
something like that unbelievable and
there's Ric Flair near
tears as he's seeing Flair this is
Sting's last match in California just
like Clash of the
Champions just like I mean just like
Clash of the champ
W I'm so happy that you're enjoying than
you thank you thank
you thank you now here we go are you
enjoying the wrestling show Honey Molly
loves it Molly has no aversion to blood
at all uh cuz here's hangman Adam pagee
this [__] was insane trying to back flip
swerve Strickland off the turnbuckle
swerve getting beat down and now swerve
grabs the chair covered in barware it's
a around Hangman's face
and now a Power Bomb through that same
chair no
less Jesus Christ look at this Chad this
is Chad's reaction to uh most of that
match he he's like paralyzed me yeah he
he sat there with his eyes wide open
watching the entire thing just a [__]
blood bath look at the blood streaming
down swerve face you can almost see how
widely he cut I'm a pro and there's a
pro so uh dude you didn't get the most
important thing the thing that made me
well fan that's right I did not shoot
this part please please at one point
hangman this is very early on in the
match swerve scores his forehead blood
is hemorrhaging out of it just pouring
hangman goes underneath his head yeah
and is just openmouth drinking his
[__] blood like a pint of it and then
spits a [__] blood Mist into the air
and I was like that that is proof of
dedication that is above and beyond I
don't know if they agreed to do that
before the match or if he was just like
in the mood like [__] it I'm going to
drink this guy's blood a lot of it like
he was under his dripping head for 10
seconds 15 seconds just filling up on
blood look that's what they call a blood
Feud baby they're getting down to the
nitty-gritty now baby and let me tell
you something I will return it to you
now this hard time blues Adam pagee and
swerve Strickland this this this Grudge
is now I don't know where they're going
to go from here swerve Strickland broke
into Adam Page's home yeah uh W couple
weeks ago and swerve won the [__]
match and I think swerve became a maid
man in aew and in the uh world of
professional wrestling although swerve
has been everywhere and if you're asking
anybody who knows it's been a long time
coming that guy [__] kicks ass but
Adam pagee grabs him by the hair
and and just was drinking his [__]
blood it I've never scene and then
everyone starts chanting Cowboy [__]
Cowboy [__] because he's the hangman
Adam page listen the [__] my favorite
wrestler now he's your favorite wrestler
Chad has a favorite wrestler that's the
night I got a favorite wrestler guy who
drank a [__] Pine of blood for my
entertainment and the rest of the show
was [__] incredible we got to see
yeah I really love
mjf Maxwell Jacob fredman had to see his
but hole a couple times what was that
now got to see his butthole a couple
times all right well hold on a second
his hisun tight little Trunks and they
went right into his ass his trunks went
up his bum bum a little bit and that's
kind of what happens when you have a
match with someone like switchblade Jay
White we got to see Chris Jericho the
who is the goat come on the oo let's
just call it like it is the man has done
everything that there is to do in
wrestling and more he's created uh more
in the world of wrestling than anyone
else in my opinion it's hard to argue
that uh Chris Jericho uh along with
Kenny
Omega who's one of the greatest
wrestlers of all time also two guys from
Winnipeg who are now going by the golden
Jets which if you know you know great uh
great name for that tag team okay versus
the young at any R it was J could say
you know what we're gonna do we're going
to talk about it a little more and dudy
after dudy because I got a [__] ton more
to say and I'll just say even though you
clearly did it to get today's episode
Championship I don't care
I loved it thank you for taking oh
cheers dudy handshake the thanks are all
due to RJ City and nugar gang thanks
boys thanks for having us holy [__] Tony
storm she [__] won the aew woman's
title her gimmick is [__] fantastic
kind of a screen siren Marilyn Monroe
very dramatic she literally and
figuratively ripped up the script in the
uh ah just so I could can't say enough
can't say enough about it we got to see
big Bill Time episode is done put your
pencils down you scored a collective
total of 90 points bringing your cumula
tally to
779 you're just
2,291 points away from 10K days this
week I want you guys to have a great
Thanksgiving week off by helping me
prepare something brand new for the
holiday the very first segment of the
week off in the history of dudy will
Premiere next week in place of a full
episode if you're wondering what that
segment might be let's just say it's
going to shove so much than giving up
your ass you'll be [__] gravy until
Christmas thank you so much for joining
us this week until next week call me
[Music]
[Applause]
dudy I bought a ticket to
the but now I come back
again why
everybody Welcome to dudy after dudy you
know what I'm saying it's that part
after the show that's still the show
because there's more show that yeah it's
dudy after
Dy hey that's not I I know trying to
drop it thank you I made it out of my
bum now I can talk normally again
instead of talking like Chad and no this
is the part of the show where [__] you
know the the the mood's a little
different in here if you're watching on
YouTube and if you're not certainly you
should consider it and while you are
please subscribe uh it's going to be a
fun show it's just a chill hang us and
uh lulio and d and our poad dudy the
pods p and uh we'll probably smark up
spark up some gabis and uh really do it
up so it's dudy after dudy you know what
I mean welcome to dudy after dudy the
flagship weekly show of dudy plus only
at
patreon.com it's tabin time can't wait
to get the final numbers on this one
I'll be back to Crown the champ in the
meantime don't do anything I wouldn't do
this is dudy after dudy
relax what are you doing come on we're
doing the show I am doing the show right
now what are you
doing uh well I've been watching what
you've been doing hats off to you
sending dudes e videos doing extra work
into the show and I appreciate that
that's not what I'm doing appreciate it
champ for [__] s and so all I'm doing is
what you're doing I'm sending dudy a
video I took at aew and asking dudy to
play it as soon as dudy gets
it what is it if you like d here's what
you
do please tell a friend then R
revie if you like d here's what you
do please tell a friend then rate a
review
if you like d what you
do please tell a friend then